>> NYPD OFFICERS SHOW UP FOR
THEIR OWN, THEY DO AND WE'LL SEE
A LOT AROUND THE COUNTRY, AS YOU
SAY.
SHIMON PROKUPECZ, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>>> IN LOS ANGELES, LOCAL
OFFICIALS DESPERATE FOR
INFORMATION ON A BLACK TEENAGER
WHO WAS KILLED.
HER BODY DUMPED, DUMPED ON A
BUSY FREEWAY.
POLICE SAY THE BODY OF
16-YEAR-OLD TIONI THIS IS THEIS
WAS DISCOVERED AND HOPE THE
REWARD WILL YIELD INFORMATION
THAT LEADS TO AN ARREST.
>> CNN'S STEPHANIE ELAM JOINING
US LIVE FROM LOS ANGELES AND
JUST HEARTBREAKING WHEN YOU SEE
THESE IMAGES OF HER AS WELL.
STEPH, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT WHO THIS YOUNG LADY WAS
AND WHY IT TOOK SO LONG TO GET
THE PUBLIC'S ATTENTION?
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT JANUARY
8th, BIANA AND JIM, SHE WAS
DISCOVERED ON THE SIDE OF THE
110 FREEWAY ON AN OFF-RAMP.
A VERY BUSY HIGHWAY HERE IN LOS
ANGELES.
ACCORDING TO THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY MEDICAL EXAMINER, SHE
DIED FROM A GUNSHOT WOUND TO THE
NECK.
WE KNOW SHE WAS DISCOVERED IN
THE EARLY MORNING HOURS.
NOT CLEAR HOW SHE GOT THERE BUT
THIS IS WHY THEY'RE TURNING TO
THE PUBLIC TO FIND OUT IF SHE
CAN, IF ANYONE KNOWS WHAT
HAPPENED TO HER.
THERE'S $110,000 REWARD FROM THE
STATE, THE COUNTY, AND THE CITY
ALL COMING TOGETHER TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT IF SOMEONE HAS ANY
LEADS THAT LEADS TO A CONVICTION
AND ARREST IN THIS CASE.
OBVIOUSLY, PEOPLE ARE UPSET.
THAT HAS BEEN SINCE JANUARY 8th.
THIS YOUNG GIRL, THAT NO ONE
SAID WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT IN THE PUBLIC.
LISTEN TO HOLLY MITCHELL, A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND
MIKE GIBSON, THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TALK ABOUT
THE CASE HERE.
>> IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE NOT
ALLOW IMPLICIT BIAS OR THE
ADULTIFICATION OF BLACK GIRLS TO
CONTINUE TO INFLUENCE THE LACK
OF MEDIA COVERAGE OR PUBLIC
OUTRAGE OVER THEIR MURDERS.
>> A 16-YEAR-OLD CHILD,
16-YEAR-OLD CHILD.
SHE'S SOMEONE'S DAUGHTER THAT
WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM US.
SENSELESSLY AND FOR THE COWARDS
WHO DID THIS, WE'RE GOING TO
MUSTER THE RESOURCES THAT'S
NECESSARY TO BRING YOU TO
JUSTICE.
>> IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT THE
L.A. COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
GEORGE GASCON INVOLVED THIS THIS
CASE WHICH IS UNUSUAL
CONSIDERING THE FACT THERE'S NO
SUBJECT OR CHARGES YET BUT
THEY'RE SAYING FROM HIS OFFICE
THEY DO BELIEVE THERE ARE SIGNS
THAT SHE MAY HAVE BEEN HUMAN
TRAFFICKED AND MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
VICTIM OF SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
BASED ON SOME COURT DOCUMENTS.
THEY'RE LOOKING TO FIND WHOEVER
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS CHILD'S
MURDER.
>> CLEARLY, THIS